is Hank back on the phone line how you
feeling bro I heard you two talking
about ranking hotels yes and I as Philip
Marlowe said there is a there is a
combination of hotels between a fleabag
and a dive and that is we know that's
what he that's how he describes a hotel
in transition okay very good
how's everything in Vegas we see videos
like thank you know it's like nothing
ever happened there is that true well
what's going on slowly slowly coming
back okay but you know restaurants are
open and the hotels are gradually like
I'm going over to my favorite place
today to register so that I don't have
to go over there and sit there I can
just play at home okay because I'm being
very careful you should I have to be I
wear my mask detector to mail okay so
you know you got a mic in my situation I
have to be damn straight but but I'm
working I'm doing CBS Sportsline and and
I'm doing ESPN this week and and I
appreciate you doing this show as always
I give you the fella ranked about the
Belmont Stakes would it's gonna be
obviously shorter than than usual no
fans but other than that we got a we got
ourselves a Triple Crown leg usually the
last it's the first this year what do
you have for me on this front well I
talked to a couple of traders who said
that there'll be an asterisk necklace
Triple Crown it's not a normal one like
you said but tis the law is the horse
you know this is a horse who won the
Florida Derby he won the big
two-year-old race last year the few
thirty and he's he stands out you know
this is the Sackett ogre group who had
funny side and they're back together
again
Barkley tagged a trainer this is a
quality or
and he's several cuts above the rest of
the field problem is you know if you bet
on them you're probably gonna get three
to five you know you're not going to
make a lot of money right so how do we
make a lot of money here then I think wa
t go I don't know I'm at a loss you know
I mean there's a couple of horses that
I'm interested in mm-hmm one of them is
modernist they weren't sure if they were
going to run him in this race or if they
were going to hold him off and totally
until one of the later derbies maybe
Indiana but Bill Mott worked him out the
other day he had a terrific work and so
he's going to go and he's a speed horse
and you never know with Maude how how
good this horse is going to be he's
gonna probably go early or at least be
close up early and the question is you
know he benefits from the shorter
distance so we'll see how far he can go
right he's won mm-hmm and there's
another horse called pneumatic
who is lightly raced he hasn't had a lot
of stakes races but here Ian third in
the mat win which was a big race at
Churchill Downs and asking us and trains
him when you say ask me it's in you got
to take a look and so I don't know how
good this source is going to be okay
those are the two horses that I'm
looking at with some kind of a chance
and so I'll play them of course I'm
going to be in action we call you Hank
so what is the before before we get to
the eat and the money talk what what is
the challenge that you're hearing from
your people that you speak to about this
reconfigured kovin nineteen Triple Crown
leg order now I mean where things are
all out of whack
what are you were you around like this I
talked to Dale Romans a lot
they all said whatever they do and
triple crown there's going to be an
asterisk there it's not a normal Triple
Crown and so it's whatever anybody says
it's not the same you know I mean you're
running the the Bell mob which normally
is the last race that not the normal
distance and it's you know it's a couple
of months out from the Kentucky Derby
which is not until Labor Day so or Labor
Day weekend so you know and and you know
here's another factor the Travers is
going to be a week before the Kentucky
Derby so you may not have you know all
the quality horses running in the
Kentucky Derby it's all out of whack
but in terms of getting the horse ready
there's there's what what what challenge
you got on that front well here's the
deal you got Maxiell for example who's
not gonna run now but you know there are
horses who are going to train up to the
Haskell and use the Haskell as the prep
for the Derby and that's the race of
Monmouth this summer so and then there's
the Travers situation where trainers are
going to have a choice do they run out
want to run the Kentucky Derby they want
to run the Travers is the big race at
Delmar this summer that should also be a
trip prep so they're gonna have to
choose the route that they're going to
go to the Derby this year rather than
take the normal you know let's do the
sanity to Derby on such a day as such a
date let's do the bluegrass on such a
date there are horses who are passing
the Belmont for running the bluegrass
and in next month because they like they
like the they like that period of time
better and prepping the Derby alright
Hank let's get to the money talk now
then um so obviously yeah it's what you
got to do right I mean so so
what are you what are you gonna do
certainly when you're expecting the
horse to sit on top to be making you you
know mere bag of shells what he got for
me on this front well I've got pneumatic
and I've got modernist those are the two
horses I like underneath maybe dr. post
so I'll take those horses and oxen and
exactas and and the only hope for might
to make money is that the test the law
stumbles out of the gate and you don't
have a mile and a half to make up the
ground okay other than if tis the law
runs his race it's it's over okay so
you're just rolling the dice by exacta
boxing the four and the ten at ten and
then nine and nine and the four and just
see what you got that's basically what
you're saying yeah and you know
something bill Mott would not be running
if he you know a lot of you know this is
points towards the Derby but it's also
if you run second in the Belmont it
means something for breeding but if
something happens and you win this race
it's a big deal alright hey before I let
you go Hank earlier in the first hour
we're just talking about me being a jet
fan for so many years and decades and
just talking about the AFC Championship
game where AJ do we picked off Richard
Todd and made me a miserable human being
for a very very long time
did did your friend may he rest in peace
Don Shula purposely leave that tarp off
the field because he knew the Jets
running game with free McNeil was coming
in and just let it rain on the Orange
Bowl did he do that on purpose
that's what the Jets fans think so that
did not happen that did not happen I
don't I don't think so yeah well
Michaels thinks it happened the jet
coach at the time oh yeah I know that
I knew walk very well you know when I
work with Jimmy the Greek and we were
getting ready for the NFL today hmm
every Friday night we had dinner with
Walt Michaels at doing Wong's a great
Chinese restaurant in New York yes well
help Timmy with his predictions he was a
great guy Walt I liked him a lot
so wait the Jets
which was helping Jimmy the Greek make
predictions based on on overs and unders
and things of that nature - and pluses
so what you're saying yes he was they
were old friends amazing oh my gosh so
what did happen on that day where did AJ
do we come from
Hank what the hell well AJ doing was a
heck of a player but you know coach you
remember AJ doing was a guy who started
out as the linemen who they moved into
the linebacker spot and the Jets didn't
couldn't handle it what was it like it
back in those days Hank is uh you know
cuz now you know now everybody's there's
a a million pregame shows but you were
there from the ground up right for the
NFL today yeah Phyllis George may she
rest in peace just passed away as well
yeah what was it like doing a show like
that
dad well it was an interesting show to
do because you know Brent Musburger had
to be one of the best coasts of all time
and we need to consider his cast you
know he didn't really have a
professional football analyst on a show
you know Jimmy was a handicapper and
Phyllis was a great person how the earth
cross was okay but there wasn't any you
know Phil Simms on that show so you know
and then Brent carried the show right
and he had to do half a dozen shows a
day it was amazing he was amazing
well he still is thank you so are you
and then were you there when he and
Jimmy uh threw down I was and I got to
tell you something just I really was you
know if you talk to people today if they
would have had to have had that skirmish
at Yankee Stadium if everybody who says
they were there were there right I can
name the people who were in the place at
the time walk me through it wasn't I was
there Mike Pearl was there other was the
producer the NFL today Todd Musburger
French brother an agent
also there was Kevin O'Malley we worked
for
CB s it's a time and a reporter for the
Washington Post who Kevin begged him not
to do the story but but he did and that
was about it my sister was there to this
and it was you know a lot of us used to
go to dinner but at that restaurant
after after the games were over so one
I'll never forget
yes when Jimmy came into the place and
he was outraged because that day Brent
had stepped on his story because he had
done the story about who the coach in
Notre Dame was going to be and it was
Jerry Faust and so when instead of
giving a lead-in Brent said so what's
this we hear about Jerry fast being a
coach at Notre Dame and Jimmy did one of
those Hama Hama Hama because you know he
stepped all over a story right so Jimmy
had all day to steam and he came into
the restaurant pear trees he walked over
to brandy said Brent you killed me today
he's the prince said I can kill you
anytime I want to on that show and Jimmy
leaned over and flap and Todd Musburger
that Brent got out of got out of his
chair and Todd Musburger yelled the
chimney is Jimmy backed up towards the
bar like he's going to grab a bottle
I'll never forget Todd yelling go ahead
Jimmy so it likes to used to do it when
you were a gangster that's the that was
the retort that was Todd's report a
record yeah and Frank Ross who we used
to call Skylab because he once showed up
as a masters with a life sentence his
briefcase
anyway Skylab grab Jimmy and in he and I
took Jimmy out and got him a taxi and
got him out of there
and that that's how it ended that's and
so what was it like on the set the next
time Hank what in the world was it like
when they finally got back to
well they they shook hands right and you
know I don't think friend ever got over
it really and you know he was astounded
I mean I stayed in the restaurant and
I'll never forget Brent said to me do
you believe he did that and I was no
longer working for Jenny I was I was I
was there for that week thing because
the Dolphins were playing there right
and I and I had my own issues with Jimmy
and I won't tell you what I said to him
but anyway yeah you know brent was
absolutely in shock that Jimmy would
come after him that way so what was a
bigger disaster their relationship or
Gerry Faust at Notre Dame Jimmie Johnson
who said a worst job on Gerry Faust Wow
ank you take care of yourself man I love
your stories your stories of the
all-time greats and yeah I really was
there and please give my best to Susie
always she always loves when you're on
the show knows that you're on and and if
we don't talk your birthday's to July
4th correct coming up big number 80 the
big 8 zero Hank you are god bless you
god bless you is exactly right I'll tell
you what you said that the last birthday
bash I was that for him at fostering
Park at lunch when he when he turned 88
I asked him what he'd like for his
birthday he said I want to be a 89 well
you know what you're your legend
yourself Hank love you truly do and I
love when you're on pasture it right
back at you
always love you and you know hopefully
we will you know chat very soon and get
you on before another big race I guess
that the next Triple Crown race so we
did the Derby
that's right we'll get John before that
as always Labor Day Labor Day week
in the meantime have a great birthday
Hank you take care of yourself thank you
so much rich you got to talk with the
same with his ankles Hank that was
awesome
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here